اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام مستمرون معكم في
هذه التغطيه للتطورات في السودان واخبار
العالم ضمن فقره الحصاد وهذه ابرز العلمي
على موقع احتدام المعارك في الخرطوم الجيش
السوداني على مواقع للدعم السريع وسط
العاصمه ويتهم عناصرها بالتسلل الى منازل
ضباط واحتجاز اسرهم وقوات الدعم السريع
ترد باتهام الجيش بقصف المدنيين في
الاحياء السكنيه وبالتمركز في مستشفى في
ام درمان
مع استمرار تدهور الخدمات والاوضاع
المعيشيه ازمه نقص الوقود والسلع الغذائيه
تتصاعد وبعد تعليق مؤقت عقب مقتل موظفين
تابعين له برنامج الاغذيه العالمي يستانف
عملياته في السودان
في مسعا لفتح باب التفاوض المبعوث الاممي
يكشف عن موافقه الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع على ارسال ممثلين الى محادثات تعقد
في السعوديه طواشن تقول ان اتصالاتها
مستمره مع الاطراف سعيا لانهاء الصراع
ومنع امتداده الى مناطق اخرى
السلطات الروسيه في القرن تعلن التصدي
لهجوم جوي اوكراني مع استمرار المعارك في
جبهات الجنوب والشرق القوات الروسيه تشن
هجمات صاروخيه على منشات في مناطق
اوكرانيه متفرقه
وكياف تقر بصعوبه الاوضاع لكنها تؤكد ان
الوضع تحت السيطره
اذا معارك مستمره تتركز في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وفي جديدها تنفيذ الجيش
لغارات وسط الخرطوم وفي ضاحيه الحلفايه
وعلى ذلك تعقب قوات الدعم السريع متهمه
للجيش باستهداف المدنيين في هذه الغارات
وتضيف ان قوات تابعه للجيش تتخذ من مستشفى
عسكري بام درمان موقعا لها لمزيد من
التفاصيل عن المشهد على الارض
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره هيثم
اويت مرحبا بك هيثم ماذا في اخر التطورات
الميدانيه
هدوء حذري يسود الخرطوم وسط الخرطوم
ومناطق الخرطوم بحري وايضا جزء منهم درمان
حينما بعد يوم حافل من المواجهات التي
كانت سيده الموقف هنا في الخرطوم كانت شد
الموجهات في محيط القصر الرئاسي حيث
استمرت لساعات طويله ايضا منطقه الخرطوم
بحري شهدت مواجهات عنيفه وقصف جوي متكرر
خلال اليوم بواسطه طيران سلاح الجو تابع
للقوات المسلحه السودانيه على مواقع
لافراد الدعم السريع في مناطق مختلفه في
منطقه الصناعات والخرطوم حي شمبات وايضا
شمال كافوري كل هذه المناطق كانت الساحه
لمواجهات ساخنه خلال اليوم كانت شكلت ابرز
ملامح اليوم الاول من هذه الهدنه السادسه
التي لم تفلح حتى الان في اخماد اصوات
البنادق واخلاص الاصوات الطلقات في
المناطق متعدده من الخرطوم ياتي هذا في
وقت يعني تتبادل فيه الاطراف الاتهامات
القصف المتبادل سواء كان من قوات الجيش
التي تقول ان قوه الدعم السريع ما زالت
تحشد قواها وتعمل على جلب المزيد من
القوات في محاوله لادخالها الى الخرطوم
وانها تتصدى لهذه المحاولات المستمره فيما
تقول القوات الدعم السريع انها تتهم الجيش
بانه يقصف مواقع لهم بواسطه الطيران وايضا
بواسطه المدفعيه من موقع السلاح الطبي وهو
مستشفى عسكري يقولون بانه يستهدف قاعدتهم
الطبيه او المدينه الطبيه بالنسبه للقوات
الدعم السريع في منطقه شنبات هذه الاحداث
تترافق في وقت تتعالى فيه الاصوات بضروره
يعني وقف اطلاق النار وحسن الاطراف على
التهدئه
وخفض التصعيد المستمر وايضا الجنوح الى
التفاوض الذي بدات يعني اطراف الدوليه
تتحدث عنه انه اصبح يعني قاب قوسين او
ادنى من الطرفين الخاصه وان هناك انفتاح
من قبل الطرفين بحسب المسؤول الاممي
والممثله الخاص للامم المتحده في السودان
كيف يبدو الوضع الان هناك
نعم الوضع الان اكثر هدوءا من بعد مقيم
الشمس حتى
مضادات الطيران بالكاد تطلق في انحاء
الخطوط البحري بعد يوم
تميز بشده القفص
المدفعي فضلا عن القصف الجوي لسلاح
الطيران الذي استهدف عده مناطق بشكل اكثر
اتساعا
مقارنه بالايام الماضيه
اي اصوات رصاص سوى
اطلاق نار من المنطقه
الغربيه قرب النيل على نواحي اندرمان لكن
الان الاوضاع اكثر هدوءا بعد يوم
يوم تميز بشده القفز بعده مناطق كما ذكرنا
في منطقه كابوري وشرق النيل ومنطقه وساره
عليهم غاز فضلا عن
قصف ودوي مدفعي في منطقه الحلفايه الى
الشمال من حي
الشنبات
الحركه
ليلا طبعا في هذه المنطقه في شارع المعونه
الرئيسي ليلا تكاد تكون معدومه
نسبه لانعدام الامن وخوفا من
الجنود الدعم السريع احمد ماذا عن الاثار
التي خلفها هذا القصف
لا نستطيع ان نستنسق عن مستوى عن الاهداف
التي اصابها الطيران الحربي لكن قطعا هناك
دواء انفجار ذوي انفجار في المنطقه
الصناعيه المعلومات التي توفرت الينا ان
لكن ادري
اهداف الدعم السريع حول هذه المنطقه التي
تعرضت الى الغصب
ثم قص قوي على شارع
حي المغتربين
فضلا عن تصعد للدخان الكثيف في مناطق
متفرقه في الصبابي وفي
كافوري ايضا المنطقه المطب الى الشرق الى
الجنوب الشرقي من كابور المنطقه الصناعيه
الصناعيه وهي منطقه سرق النيله
عرض مناطقها لقصف الطيران اشكرك احمد فضل
الصحفي بمكتب الجزيره من الخرطوم بحري
قال الناطق الرسمي باسم الجيش السوداني
العميد نبيل عبد الله في مقابله مع
الجزيره ان قوات الدعم السريع تسللت الى
منازل ضباط بالقوات المسلحه واحتجزت عددا
من الاسر
انما عندنا تم اعتراض عدد كبير مربوطات
ومتوجهون الى مقرات عملهم تم اعتراضهم في
الطريق
وتمص عليهم واعتقالهم وهذا امر
جرى منذ اليوم الاول
الاسوء من ذلك استغلوا وجود جميع الضباط
في مواقعهم وهم يتعاملوا مع هذا التمرد
تسللوا الى البيوت للاسف الشديد في
المنازل لمنازل الضباط وبعض هذه المنازل
هي منازل كانت المجاوره
لضباط نظم دخلوا هذه المنازل
تجزوا الاسر
مزيد من التفاصيل عن المشهد الميداني في
هذا العرض
[موسيقى]
لمن وصفه بالعدو بنسبه تراوح بين 45
وخمسه وخمسين في المئه وبانه مستمر
بالتصدي لمحاولات الدعم السريع تعزيز
موقفها على الارض من جهتها اكدت قوات
الدعم السريع على لساننا بقائدها انها لا
تزال تسيطر على مواقع في القصر الجمهوري
والاذاعه والتلفزيون ومطار الخرطوم
والاحياء المجاوره له وانها ايضا تواصل
التصدي لتعزيزات الجيش القادمه من
الولايات مشيره الى تمكنها من الاستيلاء
على عشرات المركبات ذات الدفع الرباعي
واسري نحو 200 من افراد قوه تابعه للجيش
كانت قادمه من ولايه كردفان
[موسيقى]
سياسيا نقلت وكاله اسوشي عن المبعوث
الاممي الى السودان ان طرفي الصراع في
السودان وفقا على ارسال ممثلين لهما الى
محادثات قد تعقد في السعوديه اضاف المبعوث
الاممي ان المحادثات ستركز على التوصل الى
وقف اطلاق نار دائم تحت رقابه سودانيه
ودوليه اضاف انه في ظل استمرار المعارك
يبقى احتمال ان تنحاز قوى مسلحه وقبليه
لاحد طرفي النزاع قائما
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم الباشا تطبيق
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بك سيد
الباشا ما دلالات قبول طرفي النزاع
بالمشاركه في هذه المحادثات التي تاتي
بمبادره امريكيه سعوديه كما قال المبعوث
الامي
سيد الباشا هل تسمعني
الباشا تطبيق الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من
الخرطوم هل تسمعني سيد الباشا
طيب ساعيد عليك السؤال
باعتقادك ما دلالات قبول طرفي النزاع
بالمشاركه في المحادثات التي تاتي بمبادره
سعوديه امريكيه كما قال المبعوثه الامامي
اليوم
للاسف يبدو ان هناك مشكله في الصوت للسيد
الباشا التطبيقي الكاتب المحلل السياسي قد
نعيد التواصل معه في سياق هذه النشره لكن
ننتقل الان الى اللواء معتصم عبد القادر
المستشار بالاكاديميه العليا لدراسات
الامنيه والاستراتيجيه الذي ينضم الينا
ايضا من الخرطوم لواء معتصم اسالك نفس
السؤال الدلالات
قبول طرفي النزاع بالمشاركه في هذه
المباحثات التي تاتي بمبادره سعوديه
امريكيه كما قال اليوم المبعوث الاممي
باعتقادك ما الدلالات من خلف هذه الموافقه
الدلاله بالنسبه
الدعم السريع
انها تحاول ان تنتقد انصافها وتجد لها في
الحياه العسكريه
ولكن يبدو ان هذه مساله بعيده المنال
بالنسبه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه هي
تنزع الى السلام وتنزع الى اي حلول يؤدي
الى معالجه القضايا السودانيه الطريقه
التي لا تحدث اي خسائر انسانيه وسط
المدنيين
القوات المسلحه الشروط ثابته
ماذا عن الدلاله من خلف موافقه القوات
المسلحه ايضا بالمشاركه في هذه المحادثات
القوات المسلحه التي تصف الدعم السريع
بالميليشيا وبالعدو في الاشاره اليها ماذا
يعني ان تقبل بالجلوس معها في والمشاركه
في هذه المحادثات
السلام هو مبدا وهدف
استراتيجيم قيم القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وتسعى اليه باستمرار هي لا تسعى للحرب هي
قوه دفاع دائما وتم الهجوم عليها وتم
الهجوم على قيادتها وهي تريد ان تعقم دماء
الشعب السوداني خصوصا ان هذه الحرب امتدت
الى يعني
هذه الميليشيا
اي محاوله الى وقف لاطلاق النار المدنيين
المسلحه
ولكن لشروطها الخاصه اذا تصير على ابعاد
القياده ميليشيا الدعم السريع المتمرده من
المسرح العسكري والسياسي السوداني بصوره
دائمه
معتصم يتوافق على اي مبادئ
باعتقادك لواء معتصم عبد القادر ما الذي
تضمنته هذه المبادره حتى يوافق عليها
الطرفين
ويوافقان على المشاركه فيها يعني ارسال
ممثلين عنهما الى الى المحادثات بشانها
هي الى الان لم ترشحي تفاصيل عن اجنده هذه
المفاوضات المرتقبه ولكن الموافقه على
مبدا اي يكون هنالك وقف اطلاق النار على
مبدا ان تعقن دماء السودانيين على هذا
الاساس الفضفاض الكبير وافقت القوات
المسلحه السودانيه ولكن هي تمضي بشروطها
خصوصا بعد ان انجزت اليوم
في القضاء على نسبه كبيره جدا القوات
المعركه تبدو انها في لحظات الاخيره ولكن
كما تعلمين اي معركه وان اي حرب لابد ان
تتزوج بالسلام لان قوات الدعم الشريعه
المغرر بها جزء كبير منها الان انضم الى
الجيش السوداني وكما تعلمين كما ذكر فائده
التمدد ان 480 ضابط او 4
من الضباط القوات المسلحه الذين كانوا
منتدبين لدى قوات الدعم السريع عادوا الى
القوات المسلحه وبقي معه ثلاثه
ضباط سوف يعودون الى القوات المسلحه
السودانيه لواء معتصم ما هي شروط القوات
المسلحه لتقبل بالنهايه
بهذا المسار خصوصا ان هذه المواجهات
مستمره على الارض تدخل اسبوع الثالث ولم
يحصل اي حسم عسكري
لواء معتصم هل تسمعني
اولا التحيه لك استاذي الكريم والتحيه
لمشاهدي قناه الجزيره والتحليل للشعب
السوداني دلالات هذه الموافقه هي تاتي من
[موسيقى]
الموافقه على طلب
يعني الدولتين اللي هي المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهذا يعني مؤشر ايجابي ان افتكر يؤدي الى
الى الى
تفاؤل كبير جدا من الشعب السوداني
ويمضي الطرفان الى التفاوض ان هذا هو
الخيار الامثل هو الخيار الاوفق لحل هذا
الاشكال الذي
تاذى منه الشعب السوداني كثيرا واعان منه
كثيرا والان نحن نعيش في ظروف ثانيه
الواقع مع الشعراوي لابد ان ينتهي
عرض الان التي تدور لا يعني
يعني
نرى يعني يتحقق نظرا مصرف
الذي نشاهدها امامنا ما زالت تدور وما زال
متمسك للمواقع التي يعني يسيطر عليها لذلك
الحل الامثل والاوفق هو التفاوض وهو
الوصول الى طاوله المفاوضات وتحديد
الاجنده نعم وهنا السؤال يعني عندما تتحدث
عن التفاوض باعتقادك ماذا يريد كل طرف من
هذه المفاوضات ما هي اجندته وما الذي يمكن
ان يفضي الى حل
اعتقد افتكر الان
المرحله هي مرحله وضع الاجنده يعني الان
لقاء طرفين هي بادر طيب ممتازه جدا كونه
يلتقي الطرفان في طاوله واحده ويبحثوا مع
المبادرين يبحثوا جميعا ما هي الاجنده
التي ممكن ان تطرح في طاوله طاوله التفاوض
وانا افتكر انه الجند الاول هو وقت دائم
لاطلاق حتى يعني
فرصه متاحه لتوسيع الان تم تسميه مندوبين
مندوب من اي طرف
اي طرف يحدد يعني
عدد من الاشخاص
ويكون له اجندته وتكون له يعني شروطه
للتفاوض لكن بالتاكيد الان هذه الخطوه هي
خطوه ايجابيه وخطوه لتقريبه
والوصول او الاتفاق على وقفه لاطلاق النار
حتى تنطلق هذه المفاوضات بصوره جاده بصوره
عمليه
للبحث عن حلول
للتفاوض حول حول يعني القضايا نقاط الخلاف
بين بين الاطراف لكن الان
وكل قليل الى الى لواء معتصم عبد القادر
يقول ان الجيش يريد السلام ولكنه لن يقبل
بوجود ميليشيا هذه ان كانت هذه اجنده
الجيش في هذه المحادثات ما هي اجنده الدعم
السريع باعتقادك باختصار لو سمحت
هؤلاء الخبراء الاستراتيجيين او ضباط
الجيش بالتقاعد هم يتكلمون يعني بعيد من
الواقع او بعيد يعني رقبات حتى الشعب
السوداني هو الان يتحدثون عن حسم للمعرفه
العسكريه وهذا مستحيل وكل الشعب السوداني
وكل الشرفاء الوطن
ما الذي يريده الدعم السريع ما الذي يمكن
ان يرضيه وان يحمله على وقف القتال
الدعم السريع يريد الان في المقام الاول
مصداقيه من الطرف الاخر وجديه واراده
حقيقيه يعني للتفاوض ثانيا يعني
قد تكون اجندته هي متعلقه بوضع يعني
القوات في المرحله القادمه وايضا التحول
المدني الديمقراطي
واستكمال ثوره يعني ديسمبر ابعاد الاحزاب
السياسيه
المتطرفه من من المشهد الذي تؤثر على على
القواعد المسلحه الان شكرا لك الباشا
تطبيق الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ضيفنا من
الخرطوم
وفي اتصال هاتفي مع رئيس مجلس السياده
وقائد الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
قال رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي رئيس جمهوريه
جزر القمر غزالي عثماني ان الاتحاد سيطلق
مبادره لمعالجه الوضع في السودان وانه
يامل ان يقبلها طرف النزاع وحسب بيان
لمجلس السياده السوداني فان رئيس الاتحاد
الافريقي بحث مع البرهان خلال الاتصال
جهود حل الازمه ودعا الى التهدئه ووقف
التصعيد
من مدينه جوندور الاثيوبيه معنا مدير مكتب
الجزيره محمد طه توكل محمد ماذا نعرف عن
هذه المبادره المرتقبه من الاتحاد
الافريقي
طبعا في الفضاء السوداني تعددت المبادرات
والنتيجه كانت الاحداث التي نتابعها لكن
موقف الاتحاد الافريقي الذي اكده سواري
اسمه
جزر القمر هو التاكيد يجب اولا سودنه
الازمه وثم يجب ان تكون ان تحل في البيت
الافريقي وثم تم تفويض منظمه الايجاد
لايجاد حل لهذا الازمه
وايجاد رشح ثلاثه دول هي جيبوتي وجنوب
افريقيا وكينيا واجروا اتصالات
وتم الاتفاق الطرفي ابلغوا الوساطه وساطه
الرقاد ورشحوا ودخلوا في التفاصيل يعني
لكن وساطه الايجاد
فدلت اولا ان يكون في لقاء في احدى عواصم
الدول الايجاد وسب بحث القضايا بدون شروط
مسبقه لكن ان يسبقه وقف اطلاق النار طبعا
لازال في تعتيم
كل طرف قدم مقترحاته لكن هناك ايجاد بترى
الاتفاق الايطالي والاتفاقيه السابقه كل
هذه يجب ان تكون في المرحله الاخرى
المرحله الاولى حاليا هي وقفه لا غنار في
هذا السياق ال سي للمره الاولى الرئيس هو
دوله مجاوره وعلى حدود طويل مع السودان
لاول مره رئيس دوله من دول الجوار يتحدث
علنا في لقاء مع التلفزيون
استغرق ساعه كامله وتحدث فيها عن ما يجري
في السودان
وجدد له لازمه السودانيه الا تحت مجله دول
الجوار وياريتنا كانت عدويتها مجمده في
منظمه اليجاد لكن هو ابدا استعداده
لتنشيط هذه الازمه وقال ان ازمه السودانيه
هي
بالاصل هي
انتاج التدخلات الخارجيه
وسمح السودان لتعدد المبادرات والتدخلات
وفي النهايه النتيجه
الفرقه احتكم وقدم خارطه الطريق لدول
الجوار وابدا استعداده بالعمل وتحدث
باسهاب وقال هو يرفض تعدد الجيوش يجب ان
يكون جيش واحد للسودان لكن مع التاكيد ان
هذا يجب ان لا يحل
المواجهات العسكريه التي نشهدها وهذه قال
من مهام الفتره الانتقاليه وليس من الفتره
الحاليه والنهايه الرئيسه للاثري فيما
يتعلق
بالرعايه الاجانب وغيرهم قال ان اريتريا
مفتوحه برا وجوا وللرعايه السودانيين ان
يدخل بدون تاشيره فبالتالي يعني هذا
التطورات الاقليميه كلها تؤكد ان اي حل
للسودان يجب ان يكون من خلال دول الجوار
وخال السفن السكه كما هو معلوم ان دولتين
كبار من دول الجوار اثيوبيا والسودان فقط
دول الايجاد كلها 300 مليون
يشعر ما يحدث في السودان يهدد امن وسلم
القاره الافريقيه السا شكرا جزيلا لك
مكتب الجزيره محمد طه توكل شكرا لك
قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كربي ان
التواصل المكثف مع طرفي الصراع في السودان
ساهم في تمديد وقف اطلاق النار امريكيا
ايضا قال قائد القوات البحريه بالقياده
الوسطى الامريكيه في مقابله مع الجزيره ان
هدف الولايات المتحده حاليا ان تراقب
وتنسق بشان التطورات بالسودان
الامر مؤسف وخطير للغايه حقيقه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده هذه منطقه يقود العمل
فيها تقود عامل فيها وزاره الخارجيه
والبحريه تتعب ذلك وقد طلب الينا توفير
سفينه حربيه والتي اخذت 600 شخص واجلتهم
الى ميناء في السعوديه
سوف طبعا انا لن اخذ في التكهنات لان
الحاله ديناميكيه متغيره لكن هدفنا حاليا
ببساطه او ان نراقب وان ننسق ولو احتاجت
وزاره الخارجيه الى اي دعم جديد نحن سعداء
لنقدمه لها
هذه المقابله مع قائد القوات البحريه
بالقياده الوسطى الامريكيه كنت اجريتها
قبل الحصاد وفيها كان حديث عن ملفات عده
من ضمنها امن مياه الخليج والشراكات
الامريكيه في المنطقه والتصعيد مع ايران
اللقاء كاملا تتابعونه بعد قليل في الحصاد
ايضا
من نيروبي ينضم الينا الخبير الاستراتيجي
في مركز ساهان للابحاث والمدير السابق
لبرنامج القرن الافريقي في مجموعه الازمات
الدوليه سيد مات برايدن ما فرص نجاح هذه
المبادره التي يتم تقديمها اليوم في
السودان بمبادره من الولايات المتحده
والسعوديه باعتقادك
اعتقد ان
الفرص
تعني اننا قد نرى
هدنه قصيره الامد وقف لاطلاق النار لاهداف
انسانيه او هدنه انسانيه تتيح لاصحاب
الاكثر من جواز سفر او الاجانب المغادره
مع احتمال ايصال مساعدات انسانيه ولكن
محدوده ولكن هذا لا يعني اطلاقا
انه اتفاق سياسي يمكن ان يؤدي الى وقفين
نهائي لاطلاق النار واستقرار الاوضاع في
السودان ولكن الا يمكن ان يفتح المجال
امام التوصل الى اتفاق سياسي خصوصا يعني
انها
خصوصا في ظل موافقه الطرفين على هذه
المبادره وارسال ممثلين عنهما
للتفاوض بشانها
اعتقد انها خطوه ايجابيه
تظهر على الاقل استعدادا من قبل الطرفين
للدخول في محادثات ولكن بمجرد اننا عرفنا
لفتره من الوقت ان القضيه الاساسيه هي ما
اذا كانت قوات دعم السريع سوف يتم دمجها
ضمن منظومه القوات العسكريه السودانيه
وانه كان هناك عرقله لهذا الموضوع لمده
اشهر وطبعا في الاسابيع الاخيره بالنسبه
الى التوصل هذه او وصول هذه المفاوضات الى
ختامها وعدم وجود اي مؤشر من قبل جنرال
الحميديه القوات الدعم السريع عن استعداده
لدمج قواته ضمن القوات المسلحه السودانيه
طبعا طالما او انا المفاوضات
مرحب بها ونحن نرى ان دول الاقليميه تحاول
ان تتدخل للقيام بواسطه ولكن بالرغم من
ذلك نرى انه هناك سيناريو خاسر في السودان
وحيث قوات الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه
السودانيه ليست مستعده لتشارك السلطه
وليست قوه الدعم السريع مستعده للاندماج
في الجيش ابقى معي سيد بات بريدن من
نيروبي تخوف مستمر دوليا واقليميا من
تصاعد المواجهات في السودان ومن تاثيره
على دول الجوار التي يعاني معظمها من
مشكلات سياسيه واقتصاديه
ما يحدث في السودان قد تتطاير شظاياه الى
دول الجوار اذا صعد الطرفان القتال لاسباب
تاريخيه واجتماعيه وثقافيه وبسبب الروابط
القبليه بين الشعبين تعد تشاد من اكثر
الدول المهدده بعدم الاستقرار بسبب ما
يجري في السودان تخشى الحكومه التشاديه من
حصول الجماعات المتمرده في تشاد على دعم
عسكري من السودان اذا فلت الوضع كما تخشى
من هجره لن تقوى على تحمل تبعاتها في
ليبيا المنقسمه على نفسها يسود التخوف من
تحرك مسلحين في اتجاه اراضيها مع العلم ان
تقارير دوليه تحدثت عن مشاركتهم في القتال
في ليبيا من قبل كما يسود التخوف من فتح
باب الهجره غير النظاميه على مصراعيه ما
يمكن ان يعمق الازمه الانسانيه لهؤلاء
المهاجرين في ليبيا اثيوبيا التي خرجت
للتو من حرب داخليه في اقليم تيجراي تخشى
من اي انفلات على حدودها مع السودان خصوصا
ان هناك نزاعا حدوديا بين البلدين كما
تخشى تدفق كبير للمهاجرين مع العلم ان نحو
50 الف اثيوبي هاجروا الى السودان خلال
حرب تيغراي الاخيره اما دوله جنوب السودان
التي استقلت عن السودان في 2011 فتعاني من
توتر مستمر منذ ذاك الحين واي انفلات في
السودان سيشكل خطرا كبيرا على استقرار هذه
الدوله الفتيه ونظرا للتوتر والصراعات
هناك هاجر النحو 800 الف شخص من جنوب
السودان الى السودان ويمكن ان تتعمق
معاناتهم الانسانيه اذا زاد الوضع سوءا في
السودان افريقيا الوسطى اتهمت من قبل
السودان بالضلوع في الصراع المسلح الذي
بدا فيها عام 2013 والان تشير تقارير
غربيه الى ان ميليشيا باغنر الروسيه تنشط
على طرفي الحدود وتتحكم في مناجم الذهب
والماس وتتخوف الدول الغربيه من اي يقوي
الوضع في السودان سطوه باغنر في المنطقه
الموقع الجغرافي للسودان يجعل تاثير ما
يجري فيه يتعدى الدول التي لها حدود معه
فكل دول الاقليم تت خوف من خروج الوضع عن
السيطره خصوصا تلك التي تواجه جماعات
المتطرفه مثل الصومال وتنزانيا والتي تعرف
ان عدم الاستقرار تربه خصمه لنمو التطرف
والارهاب تسود كل هذه المخاوف في منطقه
تشهد واحده من اسوا فترات الجفاف ما يهدد
ايضا بتفاقم ازمات سوء التغذيه والمجاعه
اعود الى مات برايدن الخبير الاستراتيجي
من مركزي او في مركز سهان للابحاث والمدير
السابق لبرنامج القرن الافريقي في مجموعه
الازمات الدوليه ضيفنا من نيروبي سيد مات
كل هذه المخاطر التي تحدث عنها التقرير من
تصدير الازمه من السودان الى دول الجوار
التي اصلا التي تعاني من ازمات لديها
مزمنه الى اي مدى يشكل هاجسا لدى القوى
الكبرى من اجل الضغط حقيقه على القوى
المتصارعه في السودان لانهاء هذه الازمه
اعتقد ان الوضع هو
فعلا مؤرق للقوى العظمى سواء كانت في
المنطقه في هذا الجزء من القاره الافريقيه
وفي منطقه الشرق الاوسط او في ادوار
الغربيه ان هذه الازمه في السودان
قد اشعلت قلقا لم تشهدها الدول الكبرى
ودول العالم منذ ازمه اوكرانيا
السودان موجوده على البحر الاحمر
ولديها وصول الى خليج عدن وان خطر انهيار
الحكومه السودانيه او بالاحرى الحكومات
السودانيه امر مقلق ومؤرق لدينا طرفا في
هذا النزاع الان ولكن
بالنظر الى كيفيه بلور هذا النزاع هناك
خطر ومجازفه كبيره من ان تصير الدوله دوله
مارقه دوله فاشله منهاره لا حكومه مركزيه
فيها وهذا ما يؤرق الحكومات الغربيه حاليا
والامم المتحده
ويدفعها الى
محاوله لعب دور الوساطه في هذا النزاع قبل
ان يزداد تشردما ويزداد الانقسام بحيث
يصعب بلابل يتعذر ايجاد حل دبلوماسي له
اشكرك
الخبير الاستراتيجي في مركز سهان للابحاث
والمدير السابق لبرنامج القرن الافريقي في
مجموعه الازمات الدوليه اذا من نيروبي
هذا وتشهد العاصمه السودانيه نقصا حادا في
الوقود حيث اغلق العديد من المحطات جاء
ذلك بسبب تدهور الاوضاع الامنيه وتوقف
الامدادات البتروليه وقد اصطفت امام محطات
الوقود عدد كبيره من السيارات وعبر
اصحابها عن استيائهم من تدهور الخدمات
وتوقف تدفق السلع الضروريه وعلى راسها
الوقود والدقيق
قال ستيفان المتحدث باسم الامين العامله
الامم المتحده ان برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
سيستانف بشكل فوري عملياته في السودان
وذلك بعد ان علقها في الخامس عشر من ابريل
الماضي بعد مقتل ثلاثه ثلاثه من موظفين
اضاف دوجاريك ان برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
يتوقع ان يبدا توزيع المواد الغذائيه في
ولايات الجضارف والجزيره وكسلا والنيل
الابيض في الايام المقبله
الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
اعلن رئيس جمهوريه القرم الموالي لروسيا
اليكسي اوكسينوف اسقاط مسيره اوكرانيه
حاولت القيام بهجوم على الجهه الغربيه من
شبه الجزيره من جانبه اعلن حاكم مدينه
سيفا ستوبل ميخائيل رازفوجياف ان اسطول
البحر الاسود بدعم من الدفاعات الجويه
تصدى لهجوم اوكرانيا بالمسيرات على
المدينه وان مسيره واحده على الاقل اسقطت
هذا وتتضارب الاخبار بشان المعارك في
باخموت وقد كسفت موسكو خلال الساعه
الماضيه قصفها على كييف ومناطق شمالي وشرق
ووسط اوكرانيا كما اكدت السلطات
الاوكرانيه تصديا دفاعاتها الجويه المضاده
للصواريخ لعده هجمات
كانوا يحفرون خندقا قبل ان يبدا القصف بين
هؤلاء الجنود الاوكرانيين وقوه فاجنر
الروسيه في بخموت مسافه سته كيلو مترات
فقط ومعارك لا سقفا زمنيا لها يحتاجون الى
يومين لانهاء الحفر تمت دائما روايتان لا
تتشابهان بشان خريطه القتال ومن يسيطر على
ماذا في بخموت التي باتت محور المعارك في
حرب دخلت عامها الثاني دون منتصر او منهزم
تتحدث وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن قصف
وحداتها منشات عسكريه اوكرانيه خلال الليل
واصابه كل الاهداف كما تواصل تقدمها في
بخموت على النقيض جاء كلام نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني التي قالت ان القوات
الروسيه فشلت في السيطره على بخموت وان
القتال مستمر كما تمكنت قوه بلادها من
استعاده بعض المواقع هناك
لا احد يمكنه التاكيد او النفي في حرب
البيانات والتصريحات بشان من يتقدم ومن
يتراجع وما هي النسب الحقيقيه لسيطره كل
طرف على الارض يبقى الثابت منذ شهور ان
اليد العليا وحتى هذه اللحظه لموسكو
ومجموعه فاجنر التي تتهم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه بالتقاعس في امدادها بالسلاح
المطلوب منذ فتره مره اخرى وجه قائد
المجموعه انتقادات لاذعه للمؤسسه العسكريه
الروسيه اوضح ان قوته لديها ما بين عشره
وخمسه عشر في المئه فقط من القذائف التي
تحتاج اليها توقع ان تشن القوات
الاوكرانيه هجوما مضادا منتصف الشهر
الجاري يمكن ان يكون ماساه لروسيا
كثفت موسكو خلال الساعات الماضيه قصفها
الصاروخي على كييف ومناطق في الشمال
والشرق والوسط من جهتها افادت السلطات
الاوكرانيه بصد دفاعاتها الجويه المضاده
للصواريخ عده هجمات دون ذكر تفاصيل اخرى
من تفاصيل الحرب المؤلمه على جميع الاطراف
جنازات ضحايا القصف والغارات هذا حداد
اومان في وسط البلاد على مقتل 23 مدنيا
اموال الغرب واسلحته وعقوباته لم تهزم
موسكو وكل جندي وترسانه روسيا العسكريه لم
تحقق النصر المبين وما دامت الحرب بلا
هوادا ولا نهايه محتمله مواكب الجنازات
الكثيره لن تتوقف هنا وهناك ايضا
ينضم الينا من اوكسفورد فرانك ليدويتش
المحاضر في الاستراتيجيات العسكريه بجامعه
والضابط السابق في المخابرات العسكريه
البريطانيه سيد فرانك كيف يمكن ان يتطور
مسار المعارك باعتقادك في اوكرانيا في ضوء
انتقال هذه المعارك على ما يبدو الى شبه
جزيره القرم
بالنسبه الى الاسره الدوليه وبنسبه الى
العالم هو في حاله انتظار
لمعركه الربيع ولكنني لا اعتقد ان هذه
المعركه سوف تكون عباره عن معركه وحيده او
هجوم وحيد بل سلسله من الهجمات ولكن هذه
العمليه لن تحصل بشكل حاسم وبالتالي هناك
تسلسل من الاحداث
ولربما نتحدث عن معركه تستمر الى العام
المقبل وكما شاهدنا في التقرير المعركه
الاساسيه هي في بخموت وهذه المعركه هي
معركه ضاريه فيها اعداد كبيره من الضحايا
واستنزاف كبير
للموارد ونحن نتحدث عن حرب داريا تحصل
الان وهذا ما نراه في محمود
وبما ان المعركه الاساسيه في بخموت
والمواجهات ضاريه هناك لماذا باعتقادك
اختارت على ما يبدو القوات الاوكرانيه
الاوكرانيه ايضا ان تنقل
موجه المواجهات في نفس الوقت الى القرن
اعتقد اننا نتحدث عن تحضير
عادي
لعمليه هجوميه الهجمات الاخيره في شبه
جزيره القرم والتي نراها الان على الشاشه
امامنا هي عمليه على او استهدفت القدرات
الروسيه اللوجستيه وهذا سوف يمنع الروس من
تعزيز قدراتهم والتجهيز للعمليات
للميدانيه حيث ان هذه العمليه ادرت الى
تدمير خزانات الوقود على وجه الخصوص طبعا
هل هذا يؤشر الى مكان الهجوم النهائي كلا
ولكننا في حقيقه الامر نحن نرى استهدافا
للقواعد اللوجستيه والاسلحه والمعدات التي
تدعم الجيش الروسي الذي باستطاعته ان
يستخدمها في المع ارك المقبل عندما
معارك الربيع المرتقبه ستكون عباره عن فتح
معارك مختلفه او جبهات مختلفه ما الذي
يمكن ان ننتظره في هذا الصدد
هذا سؤال ممتاز بالفعل
ولقد شاركت في بعثه نظمها نظمتها نظامها
مركز اوروبيه اساسيه وضمه عددا من
الجنرالات من اوكرانيا برايهم هذا من غير
المرجح ان يكون عباره كما سبق واسلف عن
عمليه واحده قويه حاسمه في
الحروب التي شاهدناها في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بل من المرجح اننا سوف نشهد سلسله
من العمليات غير الحاسمه شكرا لك
المحاضر في الاستراتيجيات العسكريه بجامعه
السابق في المخابرات العسكريه البريطانيه
ضيفه من
الى تونس حيث حمل الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل السلطه مسؤوليه اشتداد الازمه في
البلاد بسبب ما سماه الاستفراد بالراي
واختلال التوازن بين السلطات وخلال خطاب
لمناسبه عيد العمال حذر امين عام الاتحاد
نور الدين الطبوبي من تداعيات استهداف
العمل النقابي وضرب المكاسب الديمقراطيه
وفي سياق الازمه السياسيه ايضا توقع رئيس
الجبهه الخلاص الوطني المعارضه احمد نجيب
الشابي الوثول امام القضاء قريبا ملمحا
الى امكانيه التعرضه للتوقيف فيما تعرف
بقضيه التامر على امن الدوله
[تصفيق]
في العاصمه والجهات يكثف الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل رسائله الى السلطه في اليوم
العالمي لعيد العمال واهمها لاءات سابقه
اعاد الامين العام للمنظمه النقابيه
التذكره بها
واتباعنا استعداء الاتحاد والعمل النقابي
والزج بمنادي للاتحاد في السجون
وحياكه الملفات من قبل بعض الوزراء
المعادين للعمل للنقابي وشن الحملات
المسعوره
ونشر الاكاذيب وهل سنه النقابيين لن
ترهبنا
[موسيقى]
كما حمل الامين العامل الاتحاد السلطه
المسؤوليه عم اله اليه الازمه السياسيه في
البلاد متهما الرئيس قيس سعيد بالانفراد
بالراي وتجاهل اي حوار جاد مع القوى
الوطنيه
يشير الطبوب بذلك الى تصريحات لسعيد اوائل
ابريل الماضي قلل فيها من شان مبادره
للحوار الوطني وعد الاتحاد مرارا باطلاقها
بشراكه مع الهيئه الوطنيه للمحامين ومنتدى
الحقوق الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والرابطه
التونسيه لحقوق الانسان ويشتد الخلاف ايضا
بين اتحاد الشغل والسلطه في تونس حول قرض
مالي بقيمه مليار وتسعمائه مليون دولار
تسعى الحكومه للحصول عليه من صندوق النقد
الدولي بشروط يعتبرها الاتحاد مجحفه اذ
تقضي بخفض الدعم عن مواد استهلاكيه اساسيه
ورفع قيمه الضرائب اضافه الى مراجعه كتله
الاجور والتفويت في بعض المؤسسات المتعثره
لصالح القطاع الخاص وفي ضوء ارتفاع نسبه
التضخم في البلاد الى مستويات قياسيه لا
ترى الحكومه التونسيه بديلا عن القرض
الدولي لانقاذ الماليه العموميه
عيد العمال حل هذا العام على تونس في خضم
حمله اعتقالات متواصله ضد معارضين تتهمهم
السلطه بالتامر على امن الدوله بينما
تعتبر المعارضه تلك الحمله استهدافا
للخصوم وتقويضا للمكتسبات الديمقراطيه
التي حققتها الثوره رئيس جبهه الخراص
المعارضه احمد نجيب الشابي قال انه ينتظر
المثول امام القضاء قريبا ملمحا الى
احتمال توقيفه فيما يعرف بقضيه التامر على
امن الدوله الا ان الشاب ورغم تلك الهواجس
تعهد بان لا تتوقف تحركات الجبهه ولا سيما
تلك المطالبه باطلاق سراح المعتقلين
السياسيين
اترككم الان مع اللقاء الذي اجريته قبل
الحصاد مع قائد القوات البحريه بالقياده
الوسطى الامريكيه
وفيها سالته عن ابرز التحديات التي
تواجهها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
المنطقه
اولا شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه ويشرفنا
نكون معكم اعتقد انني سابدا بالحديث عن
اكثر تهديدات الامنيه المقلقه وهي ايران
وهذا يتجلى بعده طرق طبعا هناك المكون
النووي هناك الصواريخ البالسيه والصواريخ
كروسا الموجهه
والطائرات من دون طيار وانتشار كل هذه
التهديدات وايضا من خلال وكلاء ايران في
لبنان وفي اليمن وفي سوريا اذا ممكن نقول
ان هناك سؤال طبيعي ماذا نفعل ازاء ذلك
نحن نركز على شيئا تقويه الشراكات التي
لدينا في هذه المنطقه وهي كبيره وهائله
وايضا نبتكر امور وتقنيات جديده نستخدمها
لتعزيز الامن الملاحي البحري في ضوء هذا
التحدي الذي تتحدث عنه سيدنا ابي الادمرال
كيف تصف الشراكه حاليا مع دول المنطقه مع
الح لفاء التقليديين للولايات المتحده
لدينا
مزيه شراكتان مهمتان وهي القوه البحريه
المشتركه وايضا
البنيه الامن البحري المشترك ساتحدث عنهما
القوه البحريه المشتركه تتالف من 38 دوله
وهي اكبر شراكه بحريه في العالم لدينا قطع
بحريه تجوبو المنطقه وهي قوه سريعه
وديناميكيه وهذه الشراكه تعزز الامن
البحري وفي العامين الماضيه نمت هذه القوه
اضفنا اله قوه مهمات خاصه بخليج عدن وفي
العام الماضي ايضا انضمت الهند الى هذه
اذا هذه القوه الاولى والثانيه هي بنيه
الامن البحري الدولي وتتالف من احد عشر
دوله وايضا حول باب المندب ومضيق هرمز
وكانت هناك ثمانيه بلدان الان اصبحت عدد
بلدان احد عشر كلا الشركتين قويه وحيويه
وتستمر في النمو وسينضم المزيد من الشركاء
ومن خلال هذا النار اننا نعزز الامن
البحري في المنطقه هذه الشركات التي تتحدث
عنها ولا سيما مع الحلفاء التقليديين
للولايات المتحده كما ذكرت هل تتاثر
بالتطورات السياسيه واعني هنا عندما يحصل
التقارب بين ايران من جهه ودول عربيه من
جهه اخرى هل تتاثر هذه الشراكات التي
تتحدث عنها مع الدول العربيه هذه
نحن دائما نترك الدبلوماسين والسياسيين
ليتحدثوا عن الجوانب السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه لكن انا يمكننا ان نقول
مشاركاتنا قويه وتستمر في القوه وحاسه
تزداد قوه في المستقبل ساضرب لكم مثلا
الان لدينا اربع
قوى مهمات في القوى البحريه المشتركه
واحده سماء القوه وواحد صفر خمسه وتجوب
خليج عمان والشمال الخليج السعوديه كانت
تقود هذه المهمه
وراينا الربع مليار من الدولارات من
الاستثمار فيها وهذا يبين مدى قوه هذه
الشركات ولا ارى اي مؤشر على تغيرها في
المستقبل ذكرت ان التحدي الاكبر في
المنطقه هو الموضوع الايراني ردا على هذا
الكلام يقول مسؤولون ايرانيون ان المشكله
هي في التواجد التواجد الولايات المتحده
في هذه المنطقه
واذكائها لبعض الخلافات
منظوري لهذه القضيه اننا اذا ما القينا
نظر على ما حدث في الاسبوع الماضي راينا
البحريه الايرانيه وبالشكل غير قانوني ومن
خلاله هجوم على السفينه تجاريه ترفع عمل
على من دوليا ثم ادفانتي سويت راينا ذلك
على شاشات التلفزه هذه لم تكن حادثه معزول
هذه المره الرابعه عشره في عامين التي
ايران اما احتجزت واستولت او اوقفت سفينه
تجاريه بطريقه غير قانونيه وكما قلت هذا
جزء من نمط وليس حادثا معزولا بعث القلق
قلنا ان هذا يؤثر في الامن البحري والامن
البحري اذا ما تهدد سيهدد تدفق التجاره
الحره في المنطقه وهذا سيمنعني انا وجميع
المشاهدين من الاستمتاع بازدهار المنطقه
هذا ليس سببه الى اي شيء هذا الامر وهذا
التصرفات يجب ان تتوقف نابل كيف تراقبون
تطورات الوضع في السودان ما الذي يقلقكم
مما يحدث هناك
الامر مؤسف وخطير للغايه حقيقه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده هذه منطقه يقود العمل
فيها تقود العمل فيها وزاره الخارجيه
والبحريه تتعب ذلك وقد طلب الينا التوفير
السفينه حربيه والتي اخذت 600 شخص واجلتهم
الى ميناء في السعوديه وهنا اود ان اشكر
قائد الاسطول السعودي لدعم الكبير لنا في
المستقبل سوف نستمر بمراقبه الاوضاع عن
كثب والامر مقلق لكن ذات الخارجيه تتعامل
مع الموضوع ونحن سعداء بان نقدم لهم
المساعده ولكن ما هي المخاوف لديكم في حال
تطور هذا الوضع الامني كيف يمكن ان ينعكس
على الامن عموما في المنطقه
سوف طبعا انا لن اخذ في التكهنات لان
الحاله ديناميكيه متغيره لكن هدفنا حاليا
ببساطه او ان نراقب وان ننسق ولو احتاجت
وزاره الخارجيه الى اي دعم جديد نحن سعداء
لنقدمه لها طيب لو ذهبنا الى شرق اسيا
السيد نائب الادمر كيف تراقبون ايضا الوضع
هناك نسيم على خلفيه التوتر الحاصل
والمتصاعد بين الصين وتايوان ما هو دوركم
انتم في كل ما يحدث
انا اميل الى ان ننظر الى هذه القضيه من
منظور قوه بحريه الى قوه بحريه وتقوم به
الصين ومن خلال التركيز على ما نقوم به من
خلال الشراكات التي اشرت اليها
واهتمام بما نقوم به من بين الخمسه عشر
دوله لديها حدود بحريه انا اقول بثقه ان
ثلاثه عشر منها تنظر الى الولايات المتحده
على اساس ان شريك امني بالتطوع واختيار
منهم البعض الدولتان الباقيه قد تنظران
الى ايران والى الصين
الباقون ينظرون الي هناك شركاء ولا يفعلون
ذلك من خلال الكلمات بل من خلاله الافعال
وبشكل عملي اقول في العام الماضي اجرينا
تمرينا في المنطقه مع شركائنا الصين اجر
التمنينين فقط هذا العام 25 الصين اثروا
التمرينا واحدا نحن على مستويين مختلفين
تماما حاقول لك كيفيه الانخراط في هذه
المنطقه وانا اركز على الافقاع على قوه
شراكاتنا والمضي قدما الى الامام الادمن
التوتر الحاصل في شرق اسيا والمخاوف
السياسيه لدى السياسيين في الولايات
المتحده من امكانيه ان يتطور الامر هل اثر
على تواجدكم في منطقه الشرق الاوسط هل
اصبح التركيز
لامن البحار
لان البحار منصبا اكثر على ما يحدث في شرق
اسيا
اعتقد اذا ما عدنا الى الصرف الماضي
وباعلان رئيسنا القوي الذي اعلنه وعززه
وزير الدفاع عننا بالنسبه لما يخصني باننا
كبحريه مهتمون تماما ونركز على هذه
المنطقه هذا ما قاله الرئيس واكد وزير
الدفاع وهذا ما نقوم به واضافه الى
التمرينات التي تحدثت عنها وقبل عامين
اجرين ثلاثه وثلاثين في العام الذي تلا
اقمنا 77 تمرين هذا ضعف العدد ويتوقع ان
نفعل حتى المزيد هذا العام حتى الماضي
القريب كان لدينا اكثر من 42 بلدا سبعين
الفرد موجود وهذا التزام كبير اتجاه
المنطقه واقول بثقه اننا ملتزمون وهذا
الالتزام يتجلى بعملنا وانا متفائل
باستمرار هذا الالتزام ما دلاله زياده عدد
هذه المناورات كما ذكرت يعني قلت ان هناك
زياده كبيره ومع شركاء اكثر ما دلالات
القيام بكل هذه الاعمال
هذا يتسلى بعده الطرق اولا من حيث العدد
والارقام هذا يتيح لنا العمل بشكل اكثر
سيوله وسهوله وان نتحرك بسرعه اكبر
وبطريقه مباشره وذات مغزى وان نتحرك ايضا
بكفاءه اكثر حفاظا على الامن البحري اشكرك
نائب الادمر
قائد القوات البحريه بالقياده الوسطى
الامريكيه والاسطول الخامس على هذه
المقابله معنا شكرا جزيلا لك